thank you my number is 12 and for those
of you who don't have a program my name
is joe namath
i'm going to give the award for costume
design you believe that well I didn't
but it's true so here's one of the most
popular fashion models in the world and
an actress who made a stunning debut in
the last picture show civil Shepard
we've just started a third career
football player movie actors now fashion
commentator I don't know that's your job
show no no I help you this year folks
for a hint of what you'll be wearing
next year the best achievements of
costume design are Mary Queen of Scots
by Margaret first
Bedknobs and Broomsticks designed by
Bill Thomas
death and Venice designed by Piero
tossing
Nicholas and Alexandra designed by
Yvonne blade and Antonio Castilla
the matter with hello
designed by Morton back
in the rain
Yvonne Blake and Antonio Castillo to
Nicolas an eye exam
accepting the Oscar for Antonio Castilla
and herself
Yvonne Blake
ladies injured I can hardly lift it at
sitting healthy thank you so very very
much it's a great honor on behalf of
Antonio Castilla and myself and our huge
wardrobe department that we had on the
film and I suppose all one can say is
that it wasn't for the Russian
Revolution I wouldn't be